quando vuole io posso iniziare a
benvenuti nel video di farvi gido è
sponsorizzato da adidas e crocs nel crac
sono quelle che a lei immagina no ma
sono felice io è vero per un video del
genere non so se sono contenti però
vabbè sponsorizzato bella giunti ragazzi
benvenuti e non sarà questo nuovo video
io stesso non so fare la nitro signor
gatto sono sette anni che faccio questa
roba non la so ancora fare benvenuto
signor gatto nuovi dell'ifa vj che lei
oggi gioca per farmi vincere perché di
solito io mi attaccò i miei compagni per
vince se non vinco niente quindi
arrestato giocando da veramente troppo
tempo se ne rende conto se noi non
giochiamo da un sacco di tempo come
avete nessuna titolo ormai forma ed
andato iniziamo con questo nuovo gioco
che sicuramente sarà il successore si
chiama total e accord butterfly vedrete
di che cosa si tratta
tra pochissimo eccoci allora io non mi
ricordo le cose si ricorda che si potrà
ballare in questo gioco e nella loro li
si può strisciare per terra striscino
secondo che faccio vedere palazzetto
ecco ecco perfetto questo è lo stealth
game number one nel mondo non avrà
l'inventario che è sempre un po troppo
va bene decida talk è stato il castle
che ormai è diventata la nostra
posizione preferita a me sa che non ci
arriviamo noi saio eccome io ci arrivo e
come e io sto gower dresdner ai giochi
male sono caduto dentro tor caster ci
sono anche lei li veicoli vengo a
prenderla tra poco resista abbiamo mai
vinto una partita questo gioco
soprattutto ai non è mai successo che
domande share gatto
glielo dico e questa sarà la prima ecco
vinceremo noi
aspetti c'è la moto fosse meglio venga
qua non è meglio venga entry ok via si
parla ma dove c'è già è vero che cazzo
già è vero mi è arrivato esso mi ero
dimenticato che passando di là si muore
è allora la gioco un po cattivo bravo
ayami stanno uccidendo non ho più
colpita la mamma mi ammazzano crei your
gatto ci sono morto ammazzato jurassic
420 fa niente era giusto per provare
dai va bene ci siamo buona la vinta
questa parte games touch con cinque
persone va bene allora oggi altri tre
sono d'accordo oppure siamo in vantaggio
e queste vinta però basta guardare
questa parte iniziale dove diciamo che
siamo in cinque e noi in sala lo
facciamo la figura del super g
eccoci si affatichi si affatichi
facciamo cazzo se mamma mia ragazzi
quanto per arrivare a questo film
variabile ma noi non possiamo più fare
questa vita qua però siamo a 5 alive
quindi potremmo effettivamente vincere
una partita di questo gioco
l'aveva detto arriva effettivamente
potevamo farcela quindi potrebbe essere
così ho visto trovarsi qualcuno ma
scherzavo forse ma che è successo ma la
jeep sto premendo non succede niente sto
facendo be boxe
sì ma non de tende l'arma da gangster
assisi city nella mala gangsta certo ci
sono spettando la sto facendo ma solo
dietro venga qua che un casino
lavoriamo mi fido perfetto vengano
passoni turno e promesso passo solo in
mezzo agli alberi
stia tranquillo che paura sbagliato la
strada sindacato che succede ok era
l'altra dobbiamo andare un'altra parte
altra parte dove dall'afa cazzo si
mettono il signorino blu va dal blu
miami non sia attento è che cacchio è
vale che l'ho visto con l'albero sui
miei denti anch'io l'ho visto se i suoi
denti anche mancano 39 secondi poi si
richiude di nuovo la vedo male no sono
dove sono un nel turba vado via se sono
entrati in un bunker busi vengano non ci
ho sbagliato bengasi fidi cpu o
sbagliato io è stata una svista lei
capri alive prossimo detto il cerchio
parto meno venga suv e sto provando però
non sanno muso le mani sul manubrio è un
problema pasti attento che non mi me non
si preoccupi è ovviamente una parte non
sa lei che la patente conseguita otto
volte ecco eccoci a lei si era riparato
europeo bravissimo ha fatto bene ma tra
l'altro perso le pupille non so se nota
ma ho le pupille volanti forate guardi
se l'acqua diventa un passo volere
pupillo e staccate dal coro ha visto
solo che non sto guardando la strada per
fare questa cosa guardi che c'è una
macchina parcheggiata palleggiata un po
strano effettivamente questa cosa mi
puzza è un cartello stradale cosa ci
sarà scritto importa non si leggono
diamo avanti mi dica se vede una persona
da lontano che ora cecchino no ma siamo
all'interno della mappe d'inizio che
volato fortissimo la giunta dov'è la
lola pingo lo ping ato la pignata non
vedo una sega
l'app in gara giulia ho visto moglie lo
assicuro è finito mi ucciso tranquillo
però abbiamo sentito sparare quindi o si
sono sparati tra loro facendo i
simpatici e nessuno è morto
erano molto simpatici erano sparatoria
amichevole ma mi sa che colloredo lo
vede
sì gli ho sparato ha colpito me ma che
dolore no non mi passi in avanti stia
verbo l'ho colpito in testa anch'io però
non è morto attenzione ai a che fa c'era
uno dietro
live proprio lui la chiude niente
neanche contro cinque persone ma io
farei un altra partita va bene vediamo
magari entrando nella lobby dove ce ne
sono già 13
ne dubito guardi lei che fortuna che
abbiamo e le faccio vedere quanti ce ne
sono in questa lobby ti sorprenderà ha
visto la detto è però esattamente il
numero tra lago e pagherebbe uno però
d'alema tra per uno per uno stato è
uscito uno nel mentre che gli in start
quindi si stata in 11 va bene questi
aspettano per poi uscire alla fine
giusto mi sembra non fa una piega
ma è caos è un casino mi sarà è sono
atterrato anch'io però sono dentro
maccari alterata gente signor effettuati
o dove le cose non trova nulla
c'è gente neanche io trovo niente
figuriamoci caos ma non ci sono oggetti
scommetto che l'altro già armato fino ai
denti
certo nel qatar chiuso armato uccida
oggi non uscì da me ma uccida è andato
nello stereo l'arma che ho trovato non
va molto bene che cos'è la catering
pesante
mammamia invece la di a me che io ne
faccio un buon 1 ecco se uno qua io ho
sparato signor gatto via lamaro ucciso
grandissimo ho vinto io
grazie ragazzi ma è ancora vivo e c'era
un'altra quella celebrata signor gato
aiuto dove dove vengano lei l'ho visto
sull i generi ecco non vedo niente stava
lì stava lì lo giuro sono pari a ma
colpito pari bari
io non posso fare io non ho è che lo
vedo sono dietro di lui ma non ha armi
nei colpi quindi non saprebbe ucciderlo
proposito cucinavo era un amico di
corioni che sono morta di ramp up of a
perchè c'era leva iva ancora ma guarda
quanto era come si chiama
hai capito non ho capito ho capito
grazie o se intento macchina si si era
nata e dove però non la sento da sud sud
ovest
concordo e senza tronto molto più forte
il fatto è che la morte è lanciato il
bar di vediamo vediamo se lo freghiamo
grandissimo ha funzionato veramente
grandissimo uccidiamo nari acceso 21 ha
dato una data o colpito l'altro l'ho
colpito solo e basta lo cerchi vada lo
show insieme non sa soli che sono
moriamo non dava ragione a ragione
eccolo attenzione noi esistono troppi
non si lavano mandato sia tranquillo ha
dato l'uomo cetriolo non l'ho visto
vediamo ma se al centro di una missione
ma siamo forti che era chi ha paura ma
da dove mi sono io sono i morti di serie
ma da quanto è bello col cetriolo e bene
aspetti che prendo roba qua non si
capisce né abbassata barreda io vado
dall'altro vabbè dai facciamo una testa
5 live
i killer sono qua abbiamo fatto fuori
tutti ma questo ci aveva uno scudo
enorme e incroci gente allora venga
avevo nordest e gli impiegati qua ce ne
vivo non attacco da solo aspetto lei qua
stanno entrando qua perché entrando non
lo so prevedo ecco lo sto sparando
manigoldo pari pari a soli due sono i
duetti attento nome l'ho buttato terra
non è vero sono ancora vivo
ok l'ho colpito colpito una dato l'altro
lucina lei non c'e da lei e l'altro
e poi mi tiri su e vice tortona ucciso
non è vero non è davvero un genitore
uccido no ma non era andato giulio
sparato 80 colpi bene anche se adesso
che ha sparato tre si tiene il killer
armato miri davanti mi fa tutto scemo e
non fa niente non fa niente di quello
che deve fare
ultima vediamo quanto partiamo se
vediamo che ci mettiamo tanto non
partiamo va bene mi è piaciuto è
diventato messicano non secondo la non
se l'aspettava no sono un gran colpo di
scena due live benissimo spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto
la ringrazio signor gatto per averci
portato sempre in finale è difficile
vincere un gioco del genere
soprattutto i giochi dove ci vuole la
skill ma per chiamato competitivo come
sappiamo noi abbiamo fatto le
competitiva così non si può chiedere
sempre top ten è stato riferito infatti
ma l'importante è questo c'è bisogna far
capire che comunque l'importanza di
queste partite non è da sottovalutare
quindi ragazzi ve lo siete rimasti
contenti fatemi sapere se volete altri
video col signor gatto iscriviti al
canale anche del signor gatto che vi
lascio descrizione schiacciatela
campanellina così rimanete sempre
aggiornati sulle nuove uscite e noi ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo video ciao
ragazzi
[Musica]